so there are many things to criticize
from yesterday's robert muller testimony
before two different House committees
but if we zoom out and were honest with
ourselves the big picture is that robert
molars testimony confirmed that Donald
Trump is impeachable based on what
Donald Trump has done as per the Moller
report if Democrats want to pursue it
and that's a question that I brought up
yesterday with you which Democrats need
to very very soon decide yesterday I
made many of the criticisms that could
be made of the Moller testimony
Moeller was very restrained at times he
seemed confused he often was unable to
hear the questions miss stated even
whether his own report took a position
on some things he was asked about and
then was reminded after saying he has
not taken a position on that well you
took a position on it in the report at
one point he said can you remind me who
Corey Lewandowski was when he was asked
about Lewandowski and if you were
expecting fireworks of the explosive
kind then you certainly didn't get it
but robert muller did quietly confirm
truly reprehensible behavior by donald
trump which the right has been adamant
about refusing to admit even took place
and the major revelations during the
hearing were mostly just the moments
where robert muller in very short
answers often with yes or that's true
confirmed the dishonesty and the
obstructive nature of donald trump's
behavior and actions there isn't even
anything to play for you from the
republican questioning of moller their
goal was to discredit robert muller they
treated him like garbage remember muller
didn't choose to start this probe he was
appointed to run it he was brought in to
do it the idea that he was part of the
problem or part of some conspiracy to
take down Trump is laughable and
Republicans wouldn't be trying to assail
Moeller's character and the process of
the investigation itself if they didn't
believe that the content of the report
was damaging to Trump and it is so let's
get to some of the moments where our
under questioning from Democrats in the
House of Representatives on these two
committees robert muller confirmed that
yes there is impeachable action by
donald trump here he was
by congresswoman Val Demmings molar said
that Trump's written answers to his
questions number one were under oath and
number two were not answered truthfully
this is obstructive this is lying under
oath Muller told the congresswoman that
Trump's answers were quote generally
untruthful this is a massive indictment
on Donald Trump's behavior he lied under
oath to federal investigators Moeller
exposed that due to limited scope of an
of the investigation there are huge
areas about which we still know very
very little and investigations are
actually continuing that is something
Republicans have said the opposite of
Republicans have said the scope was too
wide
Moeller confirmed yesterday the scope if
anything was actually too narrow
Muller confirmed that White House
Counsel Don Magan who was pressured to
lie by the White House about whether he
was ever asked by Donald Trump to fire
the former Special Counsel Robert Muller
this is an impeachable offense in and of
itself if Democrats wanted to take it up
quote from Democrat Karen bass the
president told the White House staff
secretary Robb Porter to try to pressure
Don McGann to make a false denial is
that correct - which Robert Muller said
that's correct
that's a big deal it's easy to get lost
in the scandal numbness and in robert
muller you know seeming a little fakie
up there but this is huge that this is
obstruction of justice period muller
confirmed that a president can be
indicted after leaving office
Yoji under department of justice policy
the president could be prosecuted for
obstruction of justice crimes after he
leaves office is correct true thank you
now we knew that molar implied it in his
report and in the hearing Muller made it
abundantly clear that that's the case
and this came up against this came up
again rather with congressman Ken Buck
which is interesting because had Ken
Buck known that Robert Muller was going
to answer in this way my guess is he
wouldn't even have gone down this path
take a look
the
could you charge the president with a
trim' after he left office yes you
believe that he committed you could
charge the president nine states with
obstruction of justice after he left
office yes ethically under the ethical
standards well I'm not certain and
looked at the ethical standards but OLC
opinion says that the prosecutor why
cannot bring a charge against the
sitting president nonetheless you can
continue the investigation to see if
there any other person to might be drawn
into the conspiracy another point which
of course anyone who read the report
already knew but many viewers may not
have Moeller did not clear Trump of
obstruction of justice if you've been
following this you're reacting to me
saying yeah David we know that a lot of
people didn't know this director Muller
the president has repeatedly claimed
that your report found there was no
obstruction and that it completely and
totally exonerated him but that is not
what your report said is it correct that
is not what the report says and now
reading from page two of volume two of
your report that's on the screen you
wrote quote if we had confidence after a
thorough investigation of the facts that
the president clearly did not commit
obstruction of justice we would so state
based on the facts and the applicable
legal standards however we are unable to
reach that judgment close quote
now does that say there was no
obstruction no in fact you were actually
unable to conclude the president did not
commit obstruction of justice is that
correct well we at the outset determined
that we when it came to the the
president's culpability we needed to we
mean it we needed to go forward only
after taking into account the OLC
opinion that indicated that a president
a sitting president cannot be indicted
so the report did not conclude that he
did not commit obstruction of justice is
that correct that is correct and what
about total exoneration did you actually
totally exonerate the president no
now in fact your reports expressly
states that it does not exonerate the
president it does and your investigation
actually found quote multiple acts by
the president that were capable of
exerting undue influence over law
enforcement investigations including the
Russian interference and obstruction
investigations is that correct
correct another key moment if you try to
commit obstruction and fail that is
still a crime right yes it is
congresswoman Debbie Makar sol powell
asking about that i want to refer you
now to volume 2 page 158 you wrote that
quote the president's efforts to
influence the investigation were mostly
unsuccessful but that is largely because
the persons who surrounded the president
declined to carry out orders or accede
to his request is that right that is
accurate that is what we found and
you're basically referring to senior
advisors who disobeyed the president's
orders like White House Counsel Don
McGann former Trump campaign manager
Corey Lewandowski is that right
well we have not specified persons
betterand
well in in page 158 White House Counsel
dun McGann quote did not tell the acting
Attorney General that the special
counsel must be removed but was instead
prepared to resign over the president's
orders you also explained that an
attempt to obstruct justice does not
have to succeed to be a crime right true
simply attempting to obstruct justice
can be a crime correct yes if I am Trump
if I am a Republican if I'm in Donald
Trump's inner circle I am decidedly
relieved after these hearings despite
the fact that the content of the
hearings was extraordinarily damaging
testimony from Robert Muller it wasn't
presented in a particularly dynamic way
and the next question for Democrats is
going to be what do we do I said it
yesterday Democrats need to decide is an
impeachment inquiry going to start right
now is an impeachment inquiry going to
start but in six months timed to be more
damaging to Donald Trump or are they
moving on and they're going to
focus on 2020 whatever the answer is
I've said what I think should happen I
think there's more than enough evidence
here for an impeachment inquiry and I
think it should start whenever it is
Democrats believe it should start if
they're not going to do it then it's
time to move on the next question is and
this is going to be fun how did Donald
Trump react to all of this the answer is
like a completely unhinged disconnected
petulant child